we're going to begin with an
investigation into the murder of a young
Florida nurse and a startling Discovery
by police 26 year old Diana duvet was
last seen leaving a bar in 2014 with her
on-again off-again boyfriend who
investigators found some bizarre lies in
his past when they dug into his life
Michelle Miller reports now on the
search for Juve and her killer for this
week's 48 Hours here's an early look
on Saturday June 21st 2014 Lieutenant
Matt Harrelson and Sergeant Brad Metz
with the Vero Beach Police Department
began searching for Diana duvet and her
on-again off-again boyfriend Mike Jones
they were last seen together leaving a
bar the morning before we're in a
million different directions trying to
find her and him Diana's mother Lena
knew something was wrong when Diana
didn't return her calls and texts I was
trying to tell everybody who would
listen if she's not calling me it's
because she can't you can see the sheer
fair and panic and Lena's eyes I said
lean I promise you I'm gonna get your
daughter back for you one way or another
investigators learned that about 12
hours after Diana disappeared Mike Jones
was spotted withdrawing money from a
bank he said you know I'm not feeling
that well I'm going to be gone for a
couple of days I've got some things I
got to take care of Jones worked at PNC
Bank where he thrived at his job Urban
wealth management he had a lot of
multi-million dollar accounts a lot of
people trusted him with a lot of money
but Mike Jones also told a lot of
stories according to Ellie Sexton who
once dated him Mike told me that his
sister was dating Jason Aldean and that
he was adopted by Ronald Reagan's son
after three days of searching for Diana
investigators Trace Jones's cell phone
pings to Melbourne Florida
they alerted local police who found
Diana's car parked in a Publix parking
lot when investigators arrived they made
a startling Discovery Diana's body was
found in the trunk of her car
there are certain things in this job
that you can't unsee you can't unlive
you'll never forget
well it's always haunting when you hear
police talk like that Michelle Miller
joins us now from London where she is
covering tomorrow's coronation Michelle
good morning what do investigators think
happened to Diana
well they believe that Diana left the
bar with Jones and at some point he took
her back to their apartment they had an
argument and that's where he beat and
strangled her to death and it wasn't the
first time according to prosecutors they
say he attempted the same thing only
months earlier but she got away this is
apparently a pattern of behavior with
him not just with Diana mentally and
physically abusing women but was part of
his past well we clearly see him in the
video at the bank Michelle did they find
and prosecute Mike Jones
they did and they found him through a
series of cell phone pings followed
those pings too which led them to a
Hampton Inn they found him there they
arrested him they charged him he was
convicted and sentenced to life in
prison and that is where he is now
all right Michelle we'll be back to you
in a moment to talk about that
coordination thank you very much for now
and you can see Michelle's full report
where is Diana duvet on 48 hours
tomorrow night at 10 9 Central here on
CBS and on Paramount Plus